uh representative porker which just
stepped out for a minute and
representative Fox and representative
Skype
all right
um at this point we're looking at the HB
55 FN which we are relative to driver's
education
and what I'm looking for right now today
is just to it's a workshop so I'm just
trying to gather information
I can tell you that this last session uh
I
it was introduced and uh it I felt it
wasn't quite baked and I would like to
see an amendment to it myself personally
but also I'm hearing um
that there could been uh opportunities
through Department of Safety that maybe
some changes have been made to allow the
driver's education for 16 year olds to
have easier access to it all right so if
there's anyone out there that would like
to speak to this uh I'd be grateful to
just yeah just come on up to the
microphone and introduce you any uh so
you name and who you are and
and I don't see any orange badge so I
don't I say you're not a lobbyist
good morning my name is Jennifer Bailey
and I am the administrator for the DMV
um and I'm going to have this gentleman
good morning super Rick DuPont from the
New Hampshire State Police my supervised
driver's education
so I'm here on behalf of director
marasco he is out at a conference today
and he wanted me to discuss some of the
changes that we have been working on in
the division
um so first off there is pending
emergency rule changes being drafted by
Department of Safety legal to amend the
current 300 hours of direct supervision
of new driver's ed instructors
by a standard certificate holder to 30
hours of direct classroom supervision 15
hours of direct Supervision in a vehicle
10 of which covers the 10 one-hour
topics and the remaining five to be
applied as needed
I don't know so could you just repeat
that again just a little bit slow I want
to make sure I'm catching this because
it sounds like some big changes sure
so right now we're going to admit we're
trying to amend the current 300 hours of
direct supervision for new driver's ed
instructors
so they would now only have to do 30
hours of direct classroom supervision
which is one full class program
15 hours of direct Supervision in the
vehicle 10 of which covers the 10 one
hour topics and the remaining five to be
applied as needed
then there's also a current rule
proposal to allow primary care
physicians to assess hearing
capabilities as opposed to the current
need to complete an audiometric exam
so the hope is that these are designed
to increase driver ed instructor
all right thank you so the way I'm
seeing this and if anybody has any
questions uh just interrupt me all right
the uh so you're going from 300 hours
down to 65 hours is that what I'm
understanding
yes that's correct
what's the uh the 20 hours of like you
so it has 20 hours of additional
mentoring so what's what does that mean
um I apologize I'm not familiar with the
process this is just some notes the
director has given me to read off to you
are you familiar so originally it was
300 hours of um
directly supervised instruction after a
student after a instructor candidate
comes out of their college education
and then there's the 300 follow-up at
the driving school and right now the
mentoring is going to be
um it's it's still training but it's
just more of an oversight
um by the school owner itself to provide
additional training
to that instructor
this
is for the in order to increase the
number of instructors that where or or
driver education programs throughout the
state this is an attempt to make it more
accessible for the students this doesn't
this isn't what the students are going
to be reading no I do have more um on
the student side of things this is just
the starting point for the instructors
for the
so another question I have is the uh
besides the 300 hours which was there
originally would say we're down to 65
now at this point
was there other training for the
instructors as well I mean college
degree associates degree anything like
that they I'm just what else was what
else was required for an instructor to
become an instructor that's what I'm
getting it
that's a good question sir uh and and
Mike Doucette Mr Mike Doucette is in the
audience today and he actually runs the
program for White Mountains Community
College and he can definitely speak very
intelligently to that but there is a
program that all of our instructors are
required to participate in in order to
become to receive their certification
their initial certification and it is
completing three
um college level courses
and then the follow-up after that is
that they apply make application to the
DMV and then they have to pass a written
test and then a road test
and then once they pass all that then
they receive their provisional
certification
it's it's similar to like a youth
operator's license and then they go to
their school and then they have
additional training that um Miss Bailey
was talking about
and on that note in addition
um we are working with the White
Mountain community and they're we're
releasing a flyer advertising of 50
reduction in driver ed costs for new
all right thank you the the uh the three
courses that you're talking about uh
approximately how long do they what's
the duration
to complete those classes I think Mr
Ducette could
normally it's one semester for the first
three course
three courses take one three five week
courses and they can be done in one
semester now and be eligible to test for
a provisional instructor if they want to
go higher than that the standard
certificate there are five additional
courses they take within the next two
years
all right thank you uh go ahead you said
you had more on the draw on yeah any
yeah go ahead
um so I already mentioned the flyer
advertising the 50 reduction
um also Troop G has
um change the process of completing the
background checks for new instructors
and there has already been a decrease
scene with the amount of time they're
waiting for their background checks to
be completed
and then the last topic he wanted me to
mention is for the students we have been
working on and a soon to release a flyer
to New Hampshire driving schools to
market the New Hampshire driver ed
scholarship fund for those who can't
afford the full cost of driver education
we've worked with the community to come
on the scholarship fund do you have any
particulars on the application process
for that for the students
I personally do not I believe someone in
do you want me to step away and we can
switch out for
uh are you all set all right that's all
the topics that I had from the director
for them
my name is the chair and committee
members my name is Mike Doucette I'm a
retired Sergeant with State Police and
after retiring I have continued to teach
driver education and driving topics
since uh for nearly 40 years that I've
been doing this from when I worked at
State Police I taught the driving
program for them for 19 years
I've since when I left in my recent I
opened my own Driving School in
Littleton New Hampshire
we I also recently the new president of
the New Hampshire driveway Teachers
Association and I also teach the driver
education instructor program at White
models Community College
we have all of the instructors coming to
us from New Hampshire and Vermont out of
our College in little Littleton campus
I welcome any questions that you may
have I don't have any prepared remarks I
just we're here to try to answer
questions that you may have to have a
better idea I can talk to what some of
the conversation you just had to answer
some of those questions if that's okay
um the question about the scholarship
program the director uh when he first
took over director of motor vehicles uh
he is he established a driver education
task force trying to make things better
uh that was one of his first in and he's
been working on it tirelessly trying to
help us bring driver education to the
teens and make it more uh easily
accessible uh trying to reduce the wait
times and finally trying to find ways to
make things work to that end
we've changed our program to make our
courses the five-week format at the
college so that if a
instructor student only needs one course
they you know they aren't waiting months
to get in because we we run those first
three courses year round now used to be
you know we as a driving in school owner
I would come and find someone in April
Say Hey I want you to be an instructor
they're all excited and then you'd have
to wait till the fall to get into a
course
and then when you get to you know August
when the courses start yeah I found
something else to do I'm not going to do
it so now I'm stuck without another
instructor but now the way we have the
program set up at the college I could
hire someone tomorrow and the next class
will be a month away roughly that they
can jump into and get into there's no
prerequisites you don't have to take him
in any order uh we we're trying to help
the driving schools and we've had raving
reviews from the driving schools that
we're able to get more instructors
through I've got 19 students in my
current class I think I think five of
them from are from Vermont but we are
pushing to get as many instructors
through to the state to get them
licensed so that we can reduce that
backlog and the many other things that
we're working on we're working on a
total revamp of the driver education
rules and one of the to me one of the
biggest targets of that when it gets to
it's got to go through all the regular
channels of the administrative rules
committee and such but once that's in
place uh this if it goes as we expect if
the rules are accepted we're going to
try to roll back the a small window that
teens have to get into driver education
from 15 and nine months back to 15 and a
half and then also make it so parents
could drive with their team beginning at
15 and three months instead of 15 and a
half so that we now have as a driving
school we now have six months to get all
cram all of those newly uh wanting to be
licensed drivers into driver ed and I
think that's going to be a huge
difference in in any wait times and such
because they aren't you know if you
don't can't get into this class you've
got six months to get into another one
before your 16th birthday and I think
that's going to be a huge change and try
thank you and the driver's side right
now once you get your license what is it
16 and a half 16 you can get you after
you've taken driver's ed you can get
your license on your 16th birthday on
your 16th okay yes sir any questions
thank you Mr chairman uh so I got two
questions the first one what what's the
average hourly wage for a driver's
instructor
um for a new instructor while they're in
training I've seen uh low 20s once
they're trained and able to teach all 10
lessons and uh then their ups were in
the 25 range and I'd say 30 range for
people who can teach all the driving
in-car lessons and all of the classroom
lessons once they're trained enough to
do all of that that's a normal and some
go a little higher as well and do they
do they typically work a full 40-hour
week I mean are they like what's what's
the average like hourly so all the folks
who work for me are part-time but there
are schools that have enough volume to
have many full-time employees so
um for my myself in my situation I have
two locations Littleton and Lincoln and
um I'd say I only have one that works
near a 40-hour week the others probably
work 20s okay and um so the as far as
the curriculum I mean the spirit from
what I remember from when the um you
know the people who testified on this
and the sponsors of this bill the spirit
of this bill is kind of for parents to
be able to get more involved in like you
know the driver's education of their
their children is kind of the way that I
understood the spirit of the bill have
you looked into any kind of curriculums
or anything that maybe some kind of a
hybrid system where like in engaged
parents might be able to do that I mean
well any to me any driving school that
worth anything is getting the parents
involved yeah I mandate my parents
involvement uh because it's a it's a
Cooperative effort I've only got their
teens in the car for 10 hours you know
so that's you know if they want me to
say you know here's my new new team
never driven before teach them how to
drive yeah you know that team is not
going to get anywhere near as good as
someone who's been driving out with
their parents since 15 and a half and
gotten to drive quite a bit because I'm
then I'm teaching more you know
knowledge-based skills rather than
there's the gas pedal there's the brake
pedal uh yeah and here we go from here
you know we can get so much more and
that's not my understanding of the bill
my understanding of the bill was that it
was to uh because someone couldn't get
their their team into a program uh they
wanted to have an availability to have
parent taught driver education and we're
trying to fix that problem and with the
drive red task force and we're trying to
make that reduce those wait times
because
the folks that that at DMV have been
watching the numbers of people who come
through have never had Drive red the 18
year olds and they there's a marked
difference between those those young
adults in the in the teens who have
taken driver education okay thank you
thank you
any others
so a question I have is um
you said you're out of white mountain
right yes sir anybody else throughout
the state we there was a program at
Keene
um Keene State had a program for a
number of years and for whatever reason
and I'm I I've got to believe that uh
our our costs were one of the reasons
that they decided there was a lot of
people coming to our program because it
was twice as much to go as a new
instructor to go to their program and
they have no difference in their tuition
from their online programs versus their
in-person programs and uh ours were much
much more uh reasonably priced is all I
can I don't know why particularly but
I'm guessing that's what's happened so
you don't have to physically be at your
program you continue we have one day
that they have to come in person uh
where we do in-vehicle uh training with
with the students
and is uh going back to the driver's ed
part for the 16 year old
as far as having the parents involved
yes sir uh doesn't the current RSA say
they have to be 40 hours 40. current
rules say that they have to have 40
hours of documented time but coming to a
driver education program if they haven't
been driving at all they're far they're
way behind the curve
um which is why from day one of people
contacting my school I'm saying get out
there and drive with your team parking
lots back roads just get some comfort
level behind the wheel we'll teach them
all the stuff they need to know just get
them so that they know where the gas
pedal is and you know how much to turn
the wheel and what reaction is going to
make as they go just try to get smooth a
little bit
so I can testify to that I'm teaching a
15 year old Now parking lot back roads
yeah I think we have a lot of back roads
and not many so
um any case yes
um
any other questions anybody else
so over I'm just thinking overall I mean
we're trying to
release reduce the bottleneck which is
you know I know we signed our
child up six months in advance just to
get into a school so
and we're trying the same we're trying
as well that was one of the directors
you know biggest things when we came to
the driveway task force a year and a
half ago is we need to change things and
we've done Lieutenant Leary and all of
the uh folks all the stakeholders have
gone through all of the current rules to
try to modify them to help solve that
problem and we think we've got a good
handle on it and it's going to make a
huge difference once we get those new
rules through okay so another question I
have is as far as
parents teaching their child
Driver's Ed versus going to a school yes
you still don't recommend that I I do
not remember as I say a lot I bet 40
Years of law enforcement experience and
and 34 or so of of teaching driving I've
seen some of the people that drive out
there and I would not want them teaching
young people to drive the way they drive
so I'm just one happens what happens to
those that don't ever take drivers that
I mean we we end up with them at 18
going for license they're way behind the
curve I think uh in the last hearing we
had some of the examiners come in and
express of what they've seen of the uh
people who come in with no driver
education background uh that they can
they are they don't do as well there's a
higher failure rate and they they don't
know the rules
they get no they haven't learned them
enough to read the driver manual enough
to get past their driver education test
but uh they aren't as as skilled as the
uh the teens who come through a driver
education program
again I'm just wondering if there's you
know
the the uh bill that was put in one to
have 40 hours behind the wheel and
um
I'm just wondering if they if even if we
raise that to 120 hours for the parents
and them to give you a specific route
you know clock in clock out time stuff
like that you don't think that would I'm
just thinking people that like alternate
School homeschool stuff like that why
can't they do this as well I think I
think it's a great idea the only I I
still disagree with doing that but I
still worry about the parents that that
are working three jobs yeah I'm going to
write down that we drove today uh three
hours and uh you know just keep fudging
the numbers and we're going to have many
teens out there who have zero experience
and just get through their tests and
then
we hope that they don't crash or get
something you know one of the big things
I push with my parents is is we have a
parent night that you know as I say I
want that parent involvement we have
mandatory parent night and one of the
things I push them what other course can
your team take that if they don't get it
right that they can die
you know their mask scores they may not
be able to get the high-end computer
tech job but by not doing this right
so what about the at the older adults at
this point the 18 year old and older
that just never had a license and now
they were getting their license
are you recommending any driver's ed
with them as well or there was talk of
that but I don't think the appetite is
there to have anything along those lines
I mean I've had many I've had several
students come from like a city
environment I've never had to drive and
I want to learn and they come to see me
and I put them through you know 10 hours
of of behind the wheel and Coach them
about the rules and all that stuff and
they're they're they do well so you do
have some type of modified course for
that absolutely okay absolutely okay
and and how affordable is that because I
think oftentimes the student that Waits
until they're 18 years old is because of
the affordability and the accessibility
for a driver education program and it
depends on the person you know if if the
person has gotten any if they let's say
they're not no driving I recommend 10
hours with us at 10 hours in the car
with us that's up to them you know
they're going to see how they feel and
uh and that's up to them but we're
trying to address the cost thing going
through the director you know reached
out and uh we had a teen or an eight uh
he's probably 17 at the time was talking
about he wrote a letter to the director
saying he couldn't afford driver
education well he director invited that
teen in to speak to us all and we try to
problem solve so how can we try to make
it more affordable because back many
years ago State paid a portion of driver
education until like 2011
um and now that that money is still in
law but it never comes to Dry Ridge
education
but it uh
the
lost my thought
the affordability we're trying to
address with the scholarship program the
New Hampshire auto dealers has a
scholarship program for their mechanics
that are coming in and they're already
set up with with the type of an
application and we were refining that
application with
them and the committee to try to we're
not trying to exclude anybody we want to
include as many as possible to get that
scholarship program running they're
going to ask each Driving School to
donate if they can two seats in their
school throughout each year and then
they're going to do fundraising to the
auto dealers and elsewhere in the
community to try to create a fund that
we that they won't have to turn anybody
away and give them at least something to
make them able to afford Drive red if
and I appreciate that and I think that's
an Avenue where
it it would be very beneficial to have
more scholarships more ways to
um to help these students I think it
only benefits all of us in New Hampshire
whether you're 18 or 21 years old and
just getting your driver's license if
you have some sort of formal instruction
I also am not in favor of
um uh creating a waiver based on number
of hours that a parent helps their
student I have first-hand experience
teaching a student to drive who
um had 25 30 hours with me and then
you know uh went to their parents for
the final 10 hours that they were
required and unfortunately the parent
fabricated the 10 hours in order for the
student to get the driver's license and
I think that happens more often than not
I agree with you something I wouldn't do
something you wouldn't do but it does
happen as an example I have a a packet
of paperwork to try to help the parents
when they're out with their team in that
packet there are 11 checklist pages that
I mandate they return in at the end of
the course I have right on top but
please don't put this away please start
working on these things with your with
your team it has all the skills and
things that they're going to see and are
they doing well with it or not doing
well with it and I will tell you that
probably half of those sheets are turned
in the last night kids bringing them out
to their parents to fill them out so I
agree with you 100 it's you know there's
no control on on you know we can say
that they've got to have this but they
so right now my understanding is anybody
over 18 it's not required they take any
driving test or anything private
education at all there's no driver
education 18 you can go in on your 18th
birthday say I want my license and go
take the knowledge test if you pass it
then you'd schedule a driving exam and
and go through that but and I just want
to clarify the uh I'd either I missed it
I didn't hear it what was the cost if
someone wanted to do at least those 10
hours uh the the person coming out
outside uh for 10 hours right now it's
110 an hour because of uh the cost for
cars I've got you know 100 000 or
dollars in or more more than that in in
vehicles right now and insurance so
you're talking eleven hundred dollars
basically yes yes where is it where is
it it's someone that goes to Driver's Ed
is around seven or eight hundred yes
yeah as I've seen some schools as high
as a thousand uh
um but they're they're in that ballpark
seven eight eight hundred to 900 General
general rule
and the scholarship the scholarship
program I think is going to be awesome
and it's supposed to roll out anytime
now they've been we've been working on
it quite a while and it should be and
that's from who the Donald well the Auto
Dealers Association offered to host it
it's a it's a basically it's a it's a
development from the driver task force
where can how can we do this or whatever
and they stepped up saying we already do
the one for the mechanics and it's an
online form they fill out and you know
there's going to be a Review Committee
to see what you know we aren't looking
for financials or anything like that
because that was a big conversation you
know how deep do we want to go
to see if someone's going to be eligible
and we just ask them to tell us about
their situation and uh and and we go
from there
all right thank you and you go ahead and
just a comment because I I think you
know at a hundred and ten dollars an
hour I think that's where our problem
that's where our problem lies that's why
there's so much effort into
um uh trying to create a waiver for
parents I think you know at 18 years old
if you haven't been able to afford
driver education up until that point and
now you want to take a you know a
10-hour course that's going to cost you
more than the driver education
with the 18 year olds that are coming
quite often have been working and such
so it's it's not you you know I try to
look at the person and say you know
what's you know what's going on and it's
if they're if Financial is if it's a
financial issue I always try to help
them out you know it's it's not uh but I
have plenty of people who are 18 20 or
whatever they're out on their own and
they're working and they're doing okay
and um you know that's that's you know
the costs that we have to keep things
running in my time with 40 years
experience is worth something
um that I can help them and I can bring
them up to a a reasonable level uh in a
short amount of time and I don't often
have to do 10 but the person who has
zero experience no never driven behind
um has it ever been looked at because
I'm just thinking the economics of
multiple children somebody has four or
five kids and you know now and that's
becoming you know two degree more
popular nowadays you know in some
circles and and they have them in quick
succession so you have five kids
thousand bucks a piece going has have
you guys looked into any any kind of
program where like in my mind I can
you know like a parent goes takes a
course from you goes one time and then
they've kind of gotten this lecture you
know I I hate not lecture but you know
they've gotten the seriousness of what
the tasks they're about to embark on
um if they teach their kid driver
Driver's Ed has that has that ever been
looked at because then a family can go
in once and I mean not everybody's going
to take advantage I still think you guys
will have plenty of people coming
through
um but this gives a in my head in my
mind a responsible parent who wants to
come in take it seriously take a course
when we were first talking about this
when I when the driveway task force
started I sent out a um a survey to all
my parents for the last couple classes
saying hey there's thoughts out there of
starting a parent-taught driver
education and
um I think I had like 90 that said not a
chance
um and I had 10 percent who are
struggling with sports schedules and
they're you know working three jobs and
all those they would be the worst ones
to not have the time to do it but they
said well I can see why because of the
kids schedules and things that we they
would want to do that but
um I I wouldn't recommend it I still am
you know very opposed to doing it but I
understand there's other stakeholders
um
what is the cost for an or you can give
me a ballpark for an instructor to go
through the program right now uh each of
the three initial courses uh there's two
that are 705 dollars and the third one
is eight eight fifty five because we
have the in-person day they have they
charge a lot the college charges a lab
fee for that day
so to get them started we're twenty two
hundred dollars of thereabouts uh to get
them through the program and as we said
uh the uh
New Hampshire Department of Labor has
recognized that it's as a need so they
are going to be funding 50 of the
tuition for a new instructor to get the
uh get through the program so that's
going to be a huge help to the driving
schools
so the Department of Labor is going to
actually ship in 50 of that so
technically they'll get reimbursed 1100
and do we know how many instructors that
we have right now are uh I defer to
people Lieutenant O'Leary might know
that number
good morning sir uh Lieutenant Larry
with troopchi So currently we have a
total of 245 certified instructors
um to put that into perspective when we
left this session here last year we
certainly heard the message of
affordability affordability and
availability and you've heard uh Mr
gissette speak to the the classes the
reduction working with the Department of
Labor to get that part addressed with
instructors
um we've uh worked on our own internal
processes to help speed up the
certification process because when we
left here last year the certification
process took approximately three months
from an instructor from the time they've
completed the class to the time in which
they receive our certification was about
three months and you can imagine as a
school owner in these times it's
difficult to have somebody on ice for 90
days we were able to reevaluate that
process and reduce that wait time to
five days so the time in which they
finish the college class the time in
which they've taken the test at the DMV
and received their certification is done
now within five days as a result we've
seen in less than a year 25 new
instructors that I've gotten into
drivers education we've seen three new
locations that have opened and we have
three more locations that are pending so
to date we have 74 schools we'll have
just over that here shortly those three
additional schools that are pending are
in Prime areas such as Meredith Windham
and Nashua which will help reduce the
the stress of you know the the call and
need for instructors or instruction in
that area so I think this illustrates
that some of the steps that we've made
to help make these improvements are
already paying off where we see this you
know the additional instructors and
okay anything that we
should know that we don't know that we
didn't ask how's that you know there's
always that only last thing I would
mention is you know yes it is expensive
at driver education but if if you break
it down that we're with each student
about 46 hours
um you know per per hour rate
it's not that high per student
if you break it down and you're usually
having two or three students in a
vehicle and that's I I usually have I
usually Drive in pairs in my school but
yes a lot of schools are two or three in
the skin so one hour observing and one
yes sir just uh one last Point
um one item to consider as well is the
positive impact that this have on our
apparent drivers because you know
currently once you take driver education
you get your driver's license never
again are you put in a course or class
discuss changes in laws so when you have
a parent that's been driving for 20 to
30 years I know it seems enticing to
have that type of person or the parent
be able to offer the instruction as you
can imagine what's happening is just
like the reverse role where the the
student is coming home and discussing
these new laws and things with their
parents so there is a great Avenue here
that is allowing us to capture those
that haven't been in you know reading a
textbook or paying attention to new laws
this Avenue allows us to get some of
that information regarding like texting
and driving and all those types of laws
that have changed since they've started
driving it gets that information to them
so we use that as that Avenue
yeah very good points thank you
all right well thank you thank you very
much
would anybody else like to come up and
share anything on driver's ed
Now isn't it there we go
um you'll probably remember me but I'm
Tracy boravage I'm the president of New
Hampshire motorcycle rides okay
um I'm also the chair of the New
Hampshire newly formed about a couple
years ago newly formed motorcycle safety
task force for the state and I sit on
the traffic commission representing
motorcyclists and we are extremely
opposed to parental teaching of driver's
ed
the main reason is that most parents
have no clue how to teach their children
how to ride in and around motorcycles
much less an 18-wheeler and that's
something that actually nhmro got
accomplished 20 years ago was having
instruction for the motorcyclist as well
as 18 wheelers in the driver's education
program we also participate with them
October 14th as a matter of fact myself
and Emory Slaughter who does our ride
smart program which I think you'll have
seen
before but I will show it to you real
quick
we will be speaking to the driver's
education instructors all of them to
educate them on the motorcycling needs
and issues how to drive in and around
motorcycles and we do this typically
once a year with the instructors I don't
know how you would do that with parents
and again like I said most parents would
have no clue how to teach young drivers
how to drive in and around motorcycles
so as a motorcyclist I implore you to
really consider that the other thing I'd
like to comment on is as a parent and a
motorcyclist
I still wouldn't have wanted to teach my
son how to do that I think that there's
a reason that we have instructors and I
totally respect the idea of
homeschooling kids but you're putting
kids in vehicles that they can kill
somebody or themselves it's a big
difference between that and
homeschooling and teaching them and
education of
math so that's all I have to say have
any questions that I can answer
so my initial thought was this is uh
just instructions on vehicles and not
necessarily motorcycles I didn't I
didn't even think about motorcycles but
thanks for bringing that up
thank you for your time
okay
um
let's I just want to talk Among Us also
and then first of all I want to
apologize we did not pledge the leading
us this morning my bad I haven't been
doing this very often so we'll we'll
figure it out but any case
do you guys want to discuss this at all
right now or you know if any ideas any
thoughts as far as
the bill
the Perpetual you know the proposal I
just think
there still needs to be a lot of a lot
of work a lot of homework done a lot
more
um
a lot more participation a lot more uh
definitive answers on on creating more
schools more affordability more
I mean I'd I'd love to see more work
done on possibly bringing some kind of
hybrid system together
um because I do see the value in
traditional Driver's Ed but you know and
I come from an aviation background I've
taught people to fly very large Airlines
and you know I think the you know I I
think where the parents are actually
really helpful in a lot of this is you
know you're in the car with your kids
you're going to see a million scenarios
and it's going to be more realistic
scenarios and that's kind of in the
aviation industry that's what we've
moved into is instead of doing the row
you know procedures all the time we we
go into realistic scenarios on a
realistic you know
um situations and I think as a parent
you have so much time with your kids for
years and years and years I I think that
gives you you know that that gives you a
little bit more of an ability to kind of
demonstrate some of those scenarios and
um the motorcycles I mean up in the
Lakes Region we have so many motorcycles
it's ridiculous I mean it's it's it's
you've got to watch out but my kids now
have you know like if they're they even
watch for them they'll be like but yeah
there's motorcycle coming up you know so
I think saying that
parents have something to impart on
their children
um so I don't know I've loved to work on
this a little bit more
um somehow and maybe get something going
how do you envision like a hybrid system
any thoughts I I mean that's thinking
out loud it's dangerous
um but um I don't know I I just think
you know kind of almost like a
checkpoint system which would be some
kind of an interesting you know you give
it you give a parent a syllabus you know
that's developed by one of the schools
and it's got three phases and the parent
has to go in and do these hours because
like what was mentioned is you get a
huge checklist of stuff and I know as an
instructor sometimes you know we would
get gosh like 80 things to check off
well you only have so much time and it
is what it is so I think if you break it
up into little phases
um and then maybe check in with an
instructor at that point and if the
parents teaching it possibly have the
parent involved you know have to go with
the instructor I mean I I just think
there's options to look into
um and if again if we could make it so
one parent can go through a course and
teach their five kids I mean that that's
a huge burden lifted off but not have to
go through the whole instructor process
so that brings me back to uh Mr dessert
uh question is is there any opportunity
for a hybrid system where the parents
can do some of this they do now at this
point I get it they do the 40 hours now
but is there a possibility that they
could actually uh do a a hybrid system
of hey you know what we can give you 20
hours of training or 10 hours of
training instead of the 40 hours on
driver's ed If the parents put in you
know say 80 hours of Drive Time versus
are
so so right now we don't we don't have
any option or no hybrids out of that
right you have to either take the course
or not take the course okay all right
thank you yes sir
foreign
thank you sir
any other thoughts for today
um
I think we could uh I I don't want to
make a decision today I just want us to
think about it and maybe just come back
for one more meeting and then just call
it you know decide what we're gonna do
is that all right
all right and I'm gonna no other
thoughts anybody else going once okay
all right then I'm gonna close the
medium uh meeting thank you very much
call this subcommittee work session to
order
and uh we'll start with the Pledge of
Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic which stands one nation under
God indivisible with liberty and justice
okay we're working on House Bill 370
and House Bill 357 or 537.
both have to do with thinning of Windows
um
you have something to begin with there
uh no
I'm certainly Mr chairman
um
I think what would be best is if we
we took a look at the
the report that came back through
um
the department
and especially uh work from the last
page
um
dealing with uh RSA 266 call in 61-a for
equipment waiver for disabled
and maybe uh
ask who's ever here from the Department
that's willing to answer any questions
about
their recommendation
and bring them to the to the desk
is there anyone from uh Department Group
thank you for coming in could you
introduce yourself to good morning my
name is Jennifer Bailey I'm the
administrator three for the Division of
Motor Vehicles
my name is Maria Buckman I'm the
you yeah okay
are there any other copies over there I
I'm sorry
I had a couple of questions
um proceed thanks
so
um what we're dealing with
um is trying to create
as far as I can see try to create a
uniform
um
set of regulations not contradictory in
different rsas
dealing specifically with
um the aftermarket tent of windshield
and the two windows on either side of
the driver
right
um
I also understand that we're currently
have
federal regulations for the two windows
on either side I don't know if we have
Federal Federal Regulations dealing with
the the amount of transmittance on the
windshield but that may be coming up
later
but what we're dealing with is at what
point Beyond those Federal Regulations
should we also allow a
signed off on by the director for those
people that have
various illnesses sicknesses disease
whatever you want to call it
um that that need additional tinting
um
so that's what I'm hopeful that this is
going to give us
does that seem right to you which one
that are the paperwork you have from us
will give you what you're looking for
yes correct
um so Maria is more familiar with the
process she's actually the one that
processes the waivers currently for DMV
on these I think the confusion came so
she has it laid out here that prior to
the 2022 session
we allowed that you could have the left
the right and the windshield have not um
less than 35 percent light
transmittance
then there was a bill put through that
changed it that it could be 70 of light
transmission and the windshield was
taking other the light the left and
right was taken out of that correct out
of the waiver that's correct out of the
waiver
and and that was that 70 was the Federal
limit
how the windows are already manufactured
that way right correct did the federal
do the federal rules have
um provision for
um special exceptions I did not find one
no okay so that's left up to the state
then I gather to uh to be able to
include any further beyond that Federal
uh number if they want to have special
uh correct when I in my research I could
not find anything that gave um special
dispensation to anyone with medical
conditions under the federal law
and the Federal Regulations
um
are covering just to be clear covering
both the windshield and the two windows
on either side of the driver
I believe so yes it's for and it cannot
have less than 70 percent right and we
did not include the windshield when we
wrote that
we only included just the two windows on
either side correct well the the first
there were two changes and the first
change
um removed the side windows and had them
no less than 70 percent but it remained
that you could have a waiver for the
windshield and it could be as dark as 35
percent yes the second law changed
changed that to 70 as well okay so our
goal right now is to is to draft this so
that we have 70 in in the windshield and
the two windows on either side of the
driver
and we allow further Darkness if under
special exception correct
agreed and to bring that to it was 50 we
were going to put that at
it used to be 35 like transmittance and
it has been historically concerning
because the the 35 is very dark if you
notice on the bottom it shows that the
different Darkness so we thought the
amount of complaints that come in
um we thought that maybe 50 would be a
um
I'll let somebody else jump in here if
question
um
you held yours up and you had a dark
spot on there is there something did you
not was that something that was yeah
you didn't get that may I bring it up to
okay and I did have one question on that
do the federal standards
uh and have a requirement for General
application for new cars
I I'm sorry I'm not aware of that
okay
do you know what um just doing a quick
search here it looks like
um a lot of states are down in the like
the a lot of them are in the 30s you
know 70 seems to be pretty high is there
a reason why we wanted to be I mean
you know it looks like Massachusetts is
down in the 30s if I'm reading this
right
um it is there a reason why you wanted
it higher up here or I mean it's or you
didn't request it to be higher yeah so
the higher percentage is actually the
more
um light transmittance that comes
through so the lower the percentage is
how is how dark so in Massachusetts you
see they have blacked out windows so if
they have the 35 that's where we're
looking at with that which we used to
allow the waiver to go that low yeah
um and that's when that was changed to
put it up to the 70 we're compromising
in the middle and proposing a 50 which
still gives someone that Darkness but
doesn't block out their windshields okay
is this page in here one from your
department
because it says down to 35 was the
recommendation
I can't Mr chair
um yes that was the copy I got from
before we looked at the 35 and said 50
is probably better
so if you strike the 35 and put 50
that's what the department is that's
what the Department's recommending okay
thank you
and that's only for people with medical
waivers
that's correct Greg and there is
currently administrative rules outlining
outlining that okay and everybody else
on the side windows wouldn't be able to
the original bill
had a list of um
of conditions
that actually was attached to
a form
a letter that would be required from the
doctor primary care provider optometrist
ophthalmologist and any other medical
practitioner and they were and they had
a list of specific
diagnosis is
known to be improved by window tinting
um
has anyone checked to your knowledge
to know whether that that 35 or 50 is
your preferred wood
satisfy those conditions
currently the administrative rules have
a little bit different than the wording
that is
in the uh in the um the legislation So
currently the medical conditions under
the administrative rules are in extreme
intolerance to light allergic reactions
to the sun melanoma and lupus
um
perforia and any other medical condition
which is aggravated by exposure to the
sun
um we we have not spoken to any medical
condition any medical personnel to see
if that's
if that with a percentage would actually
alleviate
um yeah so that's that would be my
concern
um if the
if we're we're just arbitrarily because
we don't like
how this looks on this piece of paper
um going from 35 to 50 and then we find
that someone with lupus it doesn't do us
any good to go you know less
less dark than 35 percent that would be
my concern
um I don't know if that's the case I'm
just
um I think I would want to know if
somebody
could check that with
with for any of the illnesses that are
mentioned in either rules or on the on
the bill does that make sense see what
like a doctor might say would be an
acceptable level or yeah I mean if
if we're just changing it to 50 and they
say well then that renders this special
permit
mood because we really need 35 for
someone with this condition then what
have we done yeah so the other question
is did somebody just grab a list of
things that affect the eyes
I don't know
I don't know without any further
research on but why do the work if we
don't know that it's actually going to
do this
um
so that I guess we can we can still
we'll leave open the question of of the
35 to 50 change here but as far as the
rest of it I still have
other questions about the actual
process of the special permit
um
it still shows in here that it would not
exceed four years
for a quote lasting medical necessity
I'm wondering if there's what's if
there's something magical about that
that four-year time period and why it it
couldn't be something like for the life
of that or for the the length of time
that someone owns that car or something
like that
currently the um the current law
actually is for two years right and we
really don't have any kind of
recommendation for that that's totally
up to um this is a legislative change
but we would support anything I do know
that there are
um very similar to like the walking
disability placards which are good for
five years and I know this concern
whether the person changes vehicles on
this you know I mean they're supposed to
let us know but if someone else is using
the vehicle or it's registered to
someone else they could continue using
it so I think we'll see that and and
that brings up another problem here
um this this
um
waiver this special permit is for the
person not for the car correct the yes
it's well the um on the application it
is for the the patient the person who
has medical condition and they are to
list what vehicles that they have and
they're supposed to give us the copy of
their registration if they change
Vehicles they then let us know and we
will provide them a new waiver for that
vehicle okay
but if someone is there a Prohibition
anywhere that allows someone else to be
driving that vehicle
the administrative rules are silent on
that they just say that the vehicle it
doesn't even have to be owned by them
it's a vehicle that they they drive that
they drive so they're
um
yeah so so this could be for a person
who only rides and doesn't drive
we have some that are for minors just so
you know some of these come through that
a minor child has a condition and so the
the vehicle is registered by the to the
parents okay so in that case the driver
would have to be able to use that same
vehicle
I understand but the waiver is coming
through with the child's name on it yes
yeah
so the question in years past the
question would be
is is it legal for that
for the parent to be driving when the
we do very similar for the walking
disability as well if your child has a
walking disability
um you get a placard to use when you're
driving that child
foreign
but that's
doesn't affect the driver of the vehicle
the same way that this does because
you're not reducing the amount of light
coming into the car that allows the
driver to see in the case of a person
with a walking disability
uh no change to the cars needed other
than having the placard so they can park
in a convenient parking space
correct and the they can get the plates
um
representative Coker
I mean for what they're asking for right
now I yeah the problem is it gets so
complex to actually the administrative
rules you know and enforcing it it's I
mean because you got passengers it just
gets so complex to I mean if people are
that motivated to bring their tenting
down to 50 you know if that's the number
we settle on it's kind of you know it is
what it is I don't see a huge um
I don't have a giant issue with it I
don't think the complexity is adding
more complexity to the rules is going to
really solve much yep if that makes
sense so keep in mind right now we're at
70. the law that we're under right now
only allows them 70 yeah so the 50s
allowing them to go darker than what
um the other part that has always been a
somewhat of a obstacle that I've heard
complaints about is is the fact that
um
the only way that
that either the off that the officer
would know that there is a special
permit for that darkness
is if they pull the person over and then
ask for a copy of the of the permit
um
has it ever been discussed or is it does
it work in any other states that you're
aware
so that the officer would be able to
know
that this this is a
is a special permitted vehicle and and
would have a
um a reason not to stop them at that
point I am not aware of that
um it's Troop G trip Jesus
we have discussed in the past could you
sorry no you're good
um so they're they're not so to my uh
familiarity however we have discussed in
the past given the fraudulent use of
window tint waivers uh the ability to be
able to put something on a driver's
license that uh potentially would be
able to notify us that you know when you
look at the driver's license but to your
point you know we would have to stop the
individual to be able to to look at that
so that is something we could look at as
far as registration is concerned so that
when we were to run a vehicle
registration maybe there's a notation in
there that allows us to know that a
waiver is on file could be uh again that
would only
that would only show on the Regis on the
on the license you're talking the
license or the registration the
registration of the vehicle so if we
were to see the vehicle run the license
plate on the vehicle because we see the
the violation that we believe exists
when the registration populates we would
we would see that that person has a
window tint waiver
but it would have to be the owner that
has the
that has the waiver not
in case of the child for instance How
would
that would get really complicated
wouldn't it
um no in the case that she provided the
list of registrations for the registered
owner would be covered under that that
waiver so even though when you sign that
minor is driving the car but the
registration the waiver is attached to
that registration so we could still uh
you know get that information through
the registration so in that way it would
almost cover the car rather than the
individual great
is there is is window tint a secondary
or is that a primary like it's primary
primary so you could pull somebody over
for us okay
oh is there any safety like are you
aware of any safety studies that show
like I mean the the Dark of the tent the
more I mean is there any kind of
correlation that so I'm not aware of any
safety studies however excuse me I'm
sorry
um you know as law enforcement we
obviously have a serious concern safety
concerns not knowing uh being able to
see in the vehicle and historically that
has been you know our um our concerns
with allowing for the window tint
there's also concerns when people drive
at night that you know given the
darkness of the window tint it does
affect their ability to be able to see
so uh but be able to provide you with
like a safety stuff or something I just
I'm not familiar with any off the top of
my head is is 50 pretty hard I mean I
just I don't know is that pretty hard
for you guys to see through as I mean
so 50 actually would probably it you
know and Marie and I did discuss this
when when uh the presentation was made
50 I think would be uh would allow us to
be able to see in the vehicle a lot
better okay um the 35 is
docked to the point where
um I wouldn't be able to make out
anything discernible in the vehicle that
I could maybe see that there's a shadow
of a person inside of it yeah I wouldn't
be able to see what they were doing
whereas at the 50 level where where it
was mentioned before we're at 70 now so
50 is uh is something that would give us
the ability to be able to see I think
more clearly in the vehicle and identify
anything that needs to be addressed so
good thank you are you are you at all
familiar with the uh the diagnosis that
that are
out caused this special waiver yeah I I
was going to be a doctor before I became
a trooper
I'm just joking with you um I am not
familiar with with each one of the
illnesses I do know that you know in the
state of Massachusetts because
Massachusetts happened to come up
earlier you know they they categorized
their waivers just under photosensitive
uh or you know uh it's it's sensitivity
to light essentially so I think that
with our administrative rules we do
allow for other conditions that states
don't but I'm not familiar with what
each one of those uh conditions you know
pose for symptoms and what would work
best as far as the level of Darkness my
this may be off the subject I don't know
but but it seems to me that um
the people that have these diagnoses are
are not in the car 24 7. so they must be
doing something when they're not in the
vehicle and I I just wondered why they
aren't able to use whatever they use
when they're walking down the sidewalk
while they're driving
um and is and would that
change
um that that number you know I mean what
if you're if you're wearing special
glasses when you're on the sidewalk
um can you not
use those when you're driving the
vehicle as well and I'll also say
the older I get it seems like the
headlights coming back at me from the
through the windshield are getting
harder and harder to determine whether
those are high beams coming at me or low
beams coming so you'll be very happy to
know that we've proposed some
legislation this session that's going to
address just that very topic does it
involve a taser on the yeah we'll see
how it goes
um to your point sir regarding
um outside of the vehicle the
administrative rule set at DMV does
address that the doctor has to notify a
DMV that sunglasses are certified that
sunglasses are other protective
equipment will not alleviate the medical
condition so if it's a condition that
can be you know remedied by just wearing
sunglasses then they don't qualify for a
window tint waiver
so it could be a skin condition or
something along those lines that would
you know make them need that that window
tint but if if the doctor certifies that
they can use sunglasses to alleviate the
issue then they're not eligible for a
window tint waiver currently under the
administrative rules
okay and and I guess it is
there could be a complication if
somebody has prescription uh glasses
that reduce the amount of light
whether you call them sunglasses or
or otherwise and then they get in the
car and drive it
then they're doubly reducing the light
if they have a extra tinting on the
windows
okay
I mean I I just think you're kind of at
this point it's like one how how much
light do people with these conditions
actually need blocked that's kind of
what I'm curious like how low do they
want to go and two if it's acceptable at
a you know like on the other hand of
that it's the safety issue like no
matter you know you can't just black out
your windows like I mean and drive
around because it's not it's creates a
safety issue for other people so we can
if we can bring it down to a level
that's relative you know 50 seems like a
relatively safe number I mean at a
certain point is it even smart to have
the waiver and all that we just say hey
side windows are 50 that covers enough
in the medical conditions and well
that's why it's up to the director yeah
um when when the director receives the
information and the application and the
information from the doctor it would
seem to me then it's up to the director
to decide whether that's reasonable or
not it's not you or I sitting in a in a
room who does you know who doesn't have
any of the information to come up with a
number as far as I can see
each individual waiver B patient
specific well it is now yeah it is yeah
okay right and to your point sir like
you know we're looking at over a million
and a half vehicles that are registered
in the state of New Hampshire we're
discussing about less than 500 window 10
waivers right now a year so you know to
just blanket say 50 for everybody that
does increase our risk on law
enforcement and other reasons uh like
factors that we've talked about but
again you know 500 people
um it's it affects such a small group
that the this type of application
process I think is better served do you
uh can you make comment about the not to
exceed four years do you think it makes
any difference whether uh if this is a a
lasting medical necessity that it would
if we did it for the life of the that
vehicle
um would that alleviate some of the
the additional paperwork and and
reapplying and
um I I think to miss spockman's point
that
um unless required unless setting some
sort of an expiration date on these
types of waivers it's uh very difficult
to be able to keep up on the vehic
because of vehicles uh being you know
purchased traded in it's very difficult
to keep up with the registrations that
are associated with each applicant so
this this kind of forces you know that
um
that uh hey look at me on the spotlight
this forces uh the applicant to you know
essentially just make us aware again or
the DMV aware every four years regarding
those vehicles but if they did it every
time that they changed a vehicle anyway
yeah what's they're supposed to do
right it doesn't always happen well it
would have it would wouldn't the catch
um if if you are I mean when I had one
of these waivers
um the fellow that did the inspection
would ask for the waiver right and and
so if I changed vehicle
um
and tried to have it done without
notifying you folks then
the inspection so it would seem to me
for the life of the or the ownership of
that vehicle would would be the
the logical thing rather than an
arbitrary four years I mean what
so similar to like Miss Buckman had said
regarding the handicap placard that we
use or that is used it's five years
right and again that's it's it allows
the the DMV the doctors and the in the
applicant to be reevaluated to ensure
that the medical condition uh is still
exists or or if there's any changes uh
in that in that realm so but that's up
so in other words like once that once
that waiver gets issued just just like a
a disability placard you know once that
plaque card gets issued
um if we don't have a if there's no
renewal process then there's nothing
that prompts the the doctor then
reevaluate the patient to determine that
that's it's still necessary there it is
cars aren't going to last forever I mean
you know it I don't know it would seem I
don't want to get argumentative here but
it would seem to me that an arbitrary
um two or four years
makes more work for someone that
obviously has a harder time doing things
anyway
um made me need another doctor's
appointment May need you know all of
those kind of things to get the doctor
to sign
um it uh it just seems that if we if
we're gearing this almost to the vehicle
anyway
um the
the length of time that the the person
owns that vehicle would be the logical
place to make it is it just one one
comment on that so the walking
disability the reason that we do that as
well is if the um owner of the vehicle
passes away this also helps us certify
that someone has Isn't renewing their
registration because now like my town
does online renewal if I pass away
technically my husband could continue to
register my vehicle that has a waiver
and keep passing inspection if he brings
it for an inspection so this is a way to
certify as
he stated that they saw the medical
condition but also that the applicants
still alive and someone's not using that
waiver
themselves we have seen it okay
sir could I just just a point of
clarification so is it your thought that
the window 10 waiver would be by vehicle
and then at the time in which the
applicant obtains another vehicle they
would then apply for another window tint
waiver yes so if I were to keep my
vehicle for every two years I trade in a
lease well they're required to excuse me
but they're required to now right I mean
they're required when they have
you're listing each of the the vehicles
that that they drive or that they own or
whatever that right it says and when
they get a new one they're required to
notify and have that put on
my question is is it a notification or
an application meaning if they get a new
and just because I don't know the
process so if they get a new vehicle do
they have to give you a new application
with a doctor signature or they just add
that registration they just they turn in
one they're allowed to have two vehicles
registered for that so they would have
to train one and just pop it with it
okay so it's your thought then sir that
they would swap that out yeah okay I'm
with you
yeah thank you that makes sense I think
so
um
I don't think I have any I just wanted
to make sure
that um
we've only shown the one RSA 266 61.
but this does show up on a on a bunch of
other little RSA so anything that we do
would need to eliminate and I'll give
you an example there is uh there is a
265.95 for obstruction the driver's view
or riding mechanism
um
Roman 2 a the last line says no person
shall Drive upon anyway in on
show Drive upon any way any vehicle with
aftermarket tinting on the windshield as
proposed as prohibited under RSA 25.
that that as far as I'm concerned can
I'm not sure I understand yeah
so what
um we would we were adding the left and
right of the driver back to that RSA the
265.95 that would actually would add the
because right now it says windshield
on that I believe I'm looking at that uh
this this line just says no person shall
Drive upon any way any vehicle
with aftermarket doesn't even make good
grammatical sense but no person shall
Drive upon any
anyway any vehicle with aftermarket
tinting on the windshield as prohibited
under blah blah blah
and 266 if we wrote it as it's written
I apologize are you going by with the
which which Bill were you no Bill I'm
just saying this is what's in the
that they're allowed to have it if they
the complication here is that in a
different section of the RSA it says you
can't drive with any kind of aftermarket
tinting
unless authorized by the director to do
so it doesn't say that
above it does but the sentence below the
sentence after that oh I see okay I see
no person shall Drive upon any way any
vehicle with aftermarket tinting on the
windshield
you know the part about the director
is for what's before it
okay anyway that those are these are
just the technicality but I'm trying to
clear it so that
I'm I'm telling you and I I have people
that tell that go to see inspections and
they and the guy will pull out one thing
and say Here's this sentence that says
you cannot do this and and then
somewhere else it says you can
um so that's what I'm we're trying to
you are correct you are correct so in
the 2022 bill it added the aftermarket
winch tinting on the windshield so we'd
want to remove that completely but then
go back to where it was before you were
correct
the one about things yeah the other one
oh um
can you explain
uh what was the number here here it is
under the tinted glass
where aftermarket tinting is applied to
the windows
to the rear of the driver outside
tinting on no
outside rear view mirror shall be
required on both the left and right side
of the vehicle for the use of the driver
and a front seat passenger
why why would we even need outside
mirrors for the
for the use of the outside of the front
seat passenger
in all of my years of doing this that's
always been in there I I don't I don't
know I can't I can't even think of why
what we would do anything for the
for the benefit of the front seat
passenger unless I think as you had
mentioned the driver red situation but I
I don't know why would we have that in
there I
if we're changing this we may just X out
Mr oberdeen nothing no okay good
um
so it sounds like we have
some ideas here for
changes to be made that we can propose
to the committee you yes
um
is there anything else from the
Department that you would
like to comment on
um I don't think there's any other rsas
that are touched in here
um
um it was just yeah
265.95
yep those are the three I have yes
all right I think we should be able to
all right pound together or something
and give it to the committee for
consideration
now do we want to uh discuss the other
bill
um so here's my thought on the other
Bill and and you can correct me if I'm
wrong and actually the prime sponsors
here if you would like to correct us as
well
my Feeling Hit um my feeling is then we
don't have to worry about the 90 that's
in that bill yeah
that kind of was an error the the
concern that the prime sponsor has is
more the materials that are being used
to do the wavering
and to me
we don't want to get into the business
of of
specifying the materials that are used
to do the tinting
because then we run the risk of having
every time technology changes we have to
use something we have to amend things
if if all we do is is concentrate on the
the light transmittance or blocking and
I think it's
transference or transmittance that we
use it doesn't it shouldn't matter what
to us what
um flavor we use to get to that point
what materials so if if in fact that it
it blocks visible light to 50 percent
but it blocks a hundred percent of
infrared
we don't care
um
that's how that's how what to me renders
that bill move okay
now whether it needs to say in there
specifically that
the materials used to achieve this
don't matter I think I'd leave that up
to the committee to decide
I didn't I'm not I don't think I'm
technically well-versed and in that
particular case I would be in favor of
just not specifying anything at all okay
but that's what I think covers in that
bill and I think we don't need to deal
anymore we would just recommend that
that bill be uh
okay be killed did either of you have
any other further comments for us okay
um representative Hall
thank you Mr chairman
um so I think we should use the word
visible when it says light transmittance
as opposed to that solves the issue of
infrared UV right the the police
officers are worried about being able to
see into a window
visible addresses that issue because it
puts it in a certain spectrum and it's
something that can be measured as
opposed to infrared you could have 100
blockage right zero transmittance in
infrared zero transmittance in in UV and
that would be acceptable provided the
visible spectrum is at that 50 level
that you're talking about so adding one
word may solve the need to address any
material related issues does that make
sense
yeah yep
um and I just want to make sure that I
understood correctly because there's a
large number of large number of states
that have 35 or lower for their standard
and New Hampshire tends to have a bunch
of
people moving here that's a good thing
um so all of their cars if they were set
up for 35 are going to have to be redone
for either windshield or or side view
tinting if that if they move here and I
guess my concern is would we want to set
this up is it 50 for windshield and
fifty percent for left and right or zero
percent for windshield fifty percent for
left and right driver
front row seats just the uh
for the 50 tinting where is that is that
only for the rear view are you talking
for the for the
for everyone yes for everyone for the no
for everyone
so what would the standard be for
everyone all right well one of the
things that we're running into is
apparently all the federal standards and
everything are using transmission yep at
70. uh 70 transmissive
which is the opposite of of what's being
attenuated
yes
so that's that's I think that's the
number that's the numbers that were used
in this uh discussion the 70 is
transmissions and that's the federal
standard that is kind of the status quo
when I put in the bill regarding 90 I
was not aware that 70 was actually what
was used in all the windows anyway they
look clear to me
I did notice that transmittance is at 35
for the bulk of the States 34-ish states
excuse 35 or or less transmittance and
we're down to the last 16. with
no guys as a standard operating for
everybody and then you can go beyond
that you can have less transmittance
under medical conditions
and then starting with Louisiana Utah
Minnesota North Dakota Ohio Virginia
Wisconsin Alaska California Delaware
Iowa right New York Pennsylvania Rhode
Island Washington DC et cetera get up to
um for front winds front side windows
right those next to the the rear the
side view mirrors and then the
windshield
um and all those other states allow more
than 35 percent for rear windows and
so is it fit so just reiterate what you
said for the percentage what about when
what is windshield going to be going
forward what is the side view right side
the front side window is going to be
what is the rest of the car going to be
um I would propose right
70 for windshield 50 for side windows
and if you want to do 50 for the rear
windows as well you're you're just going
to have a lot of people moving to the
state who's right who started off in a
different state with 35 and now have to
have their Windows their window tinting
redone on
many of the windows in the car
well this particular Bill
specifically deals with drivers with
medical condition
and it's not even just drivers
apparently there are certain passengers
for which the vehicle is given a waiver
I think the better way to say it and the
better argument
isn't that someone would have to if they
moved here would have to change
they're tinting at at a at an inspection
time yep the better way to say it is
there's currently people driving here
legally
from
other states that that come and visit
here
um and so
some drivers are
here in their own cars with that and
some are and we're telling our citizens
that to drive at a different level right
that's
I'm in favor of a rule that works really
well for for the 95 percent of the cases
as they mentioned before 1.5 million
vehicles and 500 applications for
medical and and the medical being a a
unique set but the the rules should be
somewhat standard for everybody else and
I'm looking at the other states and
I find it hard to believe that 30 other
35 other states 34 other states can find
a way to make it work at 35 percent
around the vehicle and we're having
trouble at 70 and 50 might be the right
place to start as a stepping stone
um
and with a car that's different for the
windshield right the windshield may be
its own category but
um
side side windows at the front seat and
then back at 50 might be a reasonable
place to start and it would be in
keeping with
kind of middle of the road for the other
states what I what I kind of like about
that too is that the medical I mean I
know we're kind of going off on the side
a little bit but the medical waivers I
would if I had to bet would go down if
we allowed down to 50 you know like on
for for at least this you know the side
windows and you know the back I'd have
to go in and check but I I would I would
I would venture to say that the medical
exemptions would go down significantly
at that point and if you need it down
below 50 then you can go at the
discretion at the
we might be off into the woods here a
little bit awesome
so just as long as the rules are clear
and
interpretable by the citizens I guess
that's where I would like to go such
that it makes it easy to understand what
they're being asked be and told so that
they don't go to shop one and they're
told one thing to go to shop two that
leads to confusion that leads to all
sorts of issues
um whatever the standard is I know what
I my preference would be keeping in line
with the other 34 states but if we can
move in that direction that would be
better
um
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I wasn't going to testify
today but
listening to all this I thank you for
taking this on please introduce yourself
oh my sorry thank you thank you uh
representative Toms Falls from Hooksett
Dunbarton thank you
um
the goal I was hoping for this
subcommittee was to uncomplicate what
was complicated when we finally adopted
uh 70 for the left and right windows for
everybody and that's how this whole
thing started once we figured everybody
could have 70 percent we looked at the
35 percent said that's kind of dark so
if everybody can have 70 aftermarket
then that was removed from the medical
waiver side because you wouldn't have
needed it
then the windshield got ignored so I
mean it all got convoluted and so
hopefully at the end of the day we'll
try to uncomplicate it because you can
see by the front page
there's a lot of a lot of complaints and
a lot of people don't know what to do
with it citizens included uh enforcement
and and with the inspection stations
in terms of the 50
again I gave you this this was the
recommendations from the Department of
Motor Vehicles and Department of Safety
uh as you can see because I heard you
mentioned it before representative Coker
it goes all the way back before we even
legalized aftermarket on left and right
I hope we don't go that far it took us
11 years to get it done
um
but um I guess trying to unconfuse the
medical portion of it is is would be a
really good goal
in terms of the 50
um that might be a good compromise I can
tell you I just came back from
Pennsylvania and I heard they had 35
percent and I believe it because it
wasn't a car down there that I could
walk up to and even see the guy standing
behind the steering wheel that is
dangerously dark I don't care what other
states are doing I think 50 should be
the bottom we're looking at if you
decide to go down the road of changing
left and right for everybody
and what you want to do on the on the
medical waiver for that Darkness whether
keep it to 35 or move it up to 50. again
up to you but see conflict we
complicated it fixing it and now it's
just as in confusing trying to
uncomplicate it so good luck on your
mission and thank you very much well
what we did we did so if you go by the
statistics of the number of tint waivers
issued
we did solve that to to representative
coker's point we did reduce down
significantly the number of waivers so
so reducing it or
maybe even clarifying it
did do something we've we've knocked
down I don't know uh 600 applications
and requests so
to your point
changing it
or lowering it
further it probably would be right but
at what point do we bump up against that
safety issue that's the question and
that's yeah and again it's a kind of the
um it yeah this stuff is it it you know
I don't want to create more problems but
I I think it
you know what you were talking about
with all the administrative rules that I
I think if anybody that that 50 I mean
that's smack in the middle of most of
where the states are you know I mean
it's not I don't think it's it's it's
crazy and you know enforcing the system
will be for the medical waivers which
are the people that are really you know
who are really affected by this would be
I think you'd have a you'd be able to do
that more effectively with less waivers
to look at so
I just but I I'm okay with just I mean
I'd take note of the uh the 2023 to date
is 583 but we still have another quarter
of the year to go
we're not going to get to 1185 no but we
may get up to 800.
um
unless it's something that tends not to
occur much and we'll we'll find it all
in Winter we'll find out there's nothing
to say
that this can't be an in an incremental
uh you know if we do the 50 and then we
find that that cuts out this number of
medical waivers and then you have a
different number later on and it may be
that people
um it may go the other way it may be
that people when they find out that a
medical waiver lasts four years
well then it's worthwhile for them to go
and get one I and so the numbers may go
up you do you really I don't think
you'll ever you're chasing your tail I
think when trying to get statistics to
work your way in this no
I just said you know to me it's just if
we could be more permissive for people I
think we should be more permissive if
without affecting safe I like this guy
which is yeah I'm probably gonna get in
trouble for that
yeah that's yeah that's in my view 50
doesn't seem to be a safety issue and if
we're gonna willing to let people go
down to 35 I mean that's right
thank you representative Coker I won't
lie to you we tried for 11 years to get
aftermarket tent legalized that's why we
decided to go with the federal federal
the levels so so if if it's your wisdom
that we could probably get away with
going a little bit darker
um I mean that would that's your that's
your prerogative but I I still think
going to 35 is just way too far but it's
just my opinion for the medical waiver
no well for yeah yeah yeah I put it this
way Limo Black is 18. yeah so 35 is not
much later than that I tried at one
point to have it
be zero to be clear perfectly clear I
just wanted to film because the film is
what blocks the UV and UVA UVA and V ubb
and that was my only concern and I
couldn't get that pass uh years ago Okay
so
but I I appreciate your your
Viewpoint certainly all right I think
we've
Consolidated what we need to address and
uh it may continue make some changes uh
and basically the
the only real concern that was in HB 537
we can adopt into this one so
put all our effort into
um
HP 370.
and
amongst the things
I think we need to try to find out
um
for people with the conditions listed
how much light reduction is really
needed
um
and
things to the point where
uh not specifying particular ailments
but
um generalizing it is
uh issues involving photosensitivity
can I suggest that we don't do that
but when it comes to the committee
someone may want to testify for that
number at that point I think it's up to
us to
to amend this the way
we see fit and then and then let it let
it be on the committee to decide the
full committee to decide whether
anyone wants to testify in that okay
it's up to the chair to decide whether
there'll be any testimony during that
executive session so
okay
that would be my that would be my
recommendations
um I do think
I think if it were me I would make that
that 35 a 50
and I think I would make
um the four years for the life of the
car ownership
knowing that it would still be up to the
director to
put a put a
not to exceed the the life of the car
ownership and but other than that we're
perfectly fine with how this is I don't
mind the four-year part because that
also means that if you keep the car for
a long time
even if it especially if it was a child
the child has moved on and it's no
longer riding in that car
uh the car still has the tinted windows
so
I'm good with the life of the car
I don't know why I don't know why we'd
make someone do the extra work
oh that's true when they may have it and
and it obviously if they're driving it
and it's and they're sit driving it
safely
um yeah even if the child isn't there
for the last two years that they own the
car
um they're still driving it safely
why why make someone
I don't know it's just another piece of
bureaucracy as far as I can see and then
the only other thing that we
ought to do is to find several of the
confusing bits of language and other
chapters and
um and come up with a fix for those so
that it'll just be delete line such and
such from
266 58 blah blah blah especially one
says if the car's got tinted windows you
can't expect it at all or the one that
says that there needs to be for the
benefit the windows for the benefit of
the front seat passenger
well that's the mirror Mac
not even the window all right right yeah
I misspoke all right I think I think we
can put this yeah okay
[Music]
um
was there anybody else in in the room
that had any thing that they thought
needed to be added to this before we
close it
seeing none
I uh I'll close this
uh some committee meeting on work
session on
house bill
370 and
afternoon everybody
so welcome to Transportation this is a
work session subcommittee work work
session on House Bill 646 relative to
prohibiting oh no wrong eliminating the
vehicle inspection mandate for
non-commercial vehicles
uh the committee wasn't prepared to move
in that direction so it was agreed to
retain the bill hopefully we can work on
it and uh see if there's anything we can
move forward with
what was said at the
executive session in the spring when we
determined
um
the two to retain it
is it even though we're not by majority
looking at repealing it there are
certainly a lot of things that can be
improved
um one of the topics we looked at was
going through the rules which if you
have not gone through the rules is a
pretty daunting experience
so we are in the process of going
through them one by one and and looking
at especially the ones that people are
complaining about on a regular basis
it's not the fault anybody some of them
are just subjective and it just leaves
it into the interpretation of the
inspection stations I we have made it
through lighting so far I am not going
to have you watch us go through this
page by Page we'll do some independent
research I will schedule another
subcommittee meeting once we get to that
point and show you the ones that uh
we're put attempting to put in statute
just for clarity
um I can tell you the ones and I don't
want anybody to be alarmed especially in
the department of safety we're not going
crazy here again we're just looking at
the ones that are repeated complaints
from our citizens
um and the ones that the inspection
stations can just have too much levity
on interpreting
um
well I'd rather do that I'll give you
one example uh rotor brake rotors and
rust uh it does say any rust on the
rotor and it can be failed we all know
that's not true it shouldn't be true and
it's just too subjective so we're
proposing at this point to remove the
word rust because pitting is still there
and if you have substantial rust
obviously it's going to be pitted and if
it's pitted then we all know you're
losing your square inches on Surface
between the pad and the rotor so I get
it but I mean we all know that with the
use of calcium chloride sodium chloride
and even just to humid months you can
have rust on your rotors with it sitting
in your driveway for three days and so
again those are the things we're just
trying to clarify in statute and if we
need to remove 541a from it being
reinterpreted in the future we'll do
that as well again it's just common
sense stuff
um again I'm not going to go through
that with you it's painful to go through
them we'll continue that independently
and now I will give you the list when we
have our next meeting
the other thing we've always gotten for
complaints
um or for reasons people want to abandon
the program
predatory shops so one of the
suggestions and I'll ask somebody from
safety uh in a few minutes I did speak
with director marasco I know it's been
part of the conversation
is to possibly put a hotline or a phone
number on your inspection report so that
if people feel they've been treated
unfairly by the inspection station
whether it's they're not doing a good
enough job or whether they think they're
being oversold shouldn't matter they
should have an easy way to get in touch
with Troop G so that they can do an
audit
another thing I'm going to verify today
with safety and we'll put on the list is
teeth in any statute or any rule statute
if we need to that if if an inspection
station is going to continue
whether it be not inspect properly or
oversell
we're going to draw a line in the sand
you get so many violations before we
take the nice green and white sign off
the side of your building but
something's got to happen to stop our
citizens from being taken advantage of
again we're truly just trying to make
this a better better program
that is the bulk of what we originally
talked about
um and for reasons of retaining
um
there is another idea being floated
around I don't know if we want to attach
it to this I'll speak to my two
colleagues and their opinions there has
been some uh conversation floated around
I think we have a bill to introduced too
that might exempt the first year of a
brand new vehicle
again whether we take it up on this bill
or attach it or look at one of the I
hear five already introduced on
inspections for next year
um we'll make that determination later
what's your thoughts on either one of
you on on the scope of what we want to
do here
anybody
yep
yeah that works for me especially
digging into if we want people to have
confidence in the safety inspection
program it needs to be a safety
inspection program not a revenue
generating program we had an incident
with someone that works here
um like 10 or 12 year old Toyota Corolla
common car cheap parts once you get it
inspected said Shanita bricks okay fair
enough eleven hundred dollars
because what a lot of the shops really
like to do is rip everything off you
don't have to save any of the old Parts
by the way that's hard sometimes and
instead just assemble all brand new
parts so that price I looked up the
parts they were just going to do
calipers brakes rotors Hardware kits
whether it needed them or not I mean
everything
instead we took the we sold it don't do
it just don't do it took it to another
shop 350 bucks they changed out the
parts that were bad the car is safe
that's a safety inspection not the shop
that did the eleven hundred dollars and
we need to get a handle on that or the
Uproar against safety inspection
programs is going to continue get worse
and you'll be headed for a repeal if
this continues and it'll pass at some
thank you anything Pam yeah okay so
I guess I gotta get this a little closer
there we go
um so
conceptually I'm I actually am in
support of the idea of making sure that
there's a phone number readily
accessible that people can call doesn't
cost them anything that it gets them to
Troop G if they feel they've been
aggrieved by a workshop and um that's
only good open public government and I
think that makes perfect sense to me I
also think that
um
if a particular shop has
a more significant number of complaints
than others then there should be a
process
where that can be
um
I hate to use the word adjudicated but
it could be looked at it for sure my
only concern with that piece of it is do
we have
um
I know we have data about the numbers of
yearly inspections that are taking place
but have have either of you gentlemen
receive the number of complaints that
have been received
because I think that's you know a piece
of the data that we should have as we
continue the discussion
um you know if it's 18 complaints a year
inspections then I I you know I I think
we have to take a look at that if it's
18 inspections
all of which come from one shop then
that's certainly a concern
um so that's you know I I think we we
need a little more data to to move on
those two fronts and I think that's uh
worthwhile place to continue
[Music]
um
I
I think that's you know in terms of the
uh
coming having another subcommittee
meeting to
uh look at
these particular points would be useful
for both the industry and for us
and I'm okay with that too
um
relative to moving
taking a look at some more substantive
changes
um
rather than tacking it on to a bill
after just you know a
the amount of time that we have
available to us this year I would much
rather prefer to see the legislation
that is submitted and then have real
actual subcommittee work prior to
executing with plenty of time to take up
any other possible more if the if
there's a need for more substantive
changes that's that's my view
fair enough and I have to be honest with
you the more I think about it I think
that is the right way to go it seems
like we have other vehicles and we have
a bill that's kind of specific so uh to
keep it simple and to risk torpedoing
good work on the rest of it I think we
can separate the two you agree
uh okay I think the next step and some
of the questions you had representative
Sykes I'll ask somebody from the
Department of Safety to come up uh we've
got a couple of questions I know
representative Sykes had one
specifically
if we can't get the answer right this
moment certainly you can have it for us
for the if it exists the data for the
next subcommittee meeting
yeah
um and then for lieutenant O'Leary you
were out of the room I think just we're
going over the scope real quickly we're
not going to do it today and bore
everybody but we are going through the
rules and just looking at the ones that
that I've received complaints on in
terms of their subjectivity
um when we have those formalized we'll
schedule another another meeting we can
go over them but speaking of complaints
one of the questions representative
Sykes has do we have any data on how
many complaints do we get on an annual
basis I'm I can speak for myself as a
legislator I get a ton of them but I
don't have a number sure now
representative I appreciate the question
uh so after leaving the session last
year that question was posed and we went
back to look at you know what do we have
for numbers available and what we
quickly Learned was the challenges that
are faced by the consumer is that there
is not a direct line for complaints to
be received the complaints are some go
to Department of Justice uh consumer
protection some go to to the dealer
inspection desk cut some come to Troop G
directly so I could provide you with
numbers of cases that we've had for
complaints for Troop G alone but I
wouldn't be doing you a service and
really giving you a complete number so
that that is the challenge that we that
we found leaving here but to help
Rectify that situation and I don't know
if this is already discussed if it is
you can shut me off to help Rectify that
situation we met with the Attorney
General's office consumer protection
attorney along with the DMV and
obviously Troop G and had a discussion
on how can we centralize these
complaints and therefore it makes it
much easier for the general public to
call or email one number or one email
address so that now we can start to
collect the data to show you know what
we are receiving for complaints so
that's the direction that we've worked
we're sitting in a pretty good
foundation moving forward with that and
I'd be more than happy to discuss that
with you but I just want to let you know
that that's the changes we made since
last session to help centralize those
complaints as they come in so we can
um I know you've run it through your
legal department or even Beyond has it
come back in time to see any possible
language
so I can share with you the language
that we proposed it's uh to my knowledge
has not been necessarily approved yet by
our legal or by DMV legal I should say
but I would like to share it with you
just so you have an idea of of what we
are looking to do
one of the discussions that came up or
ideas that came up last year was to
maybe have signage at the locations of
where the inspection stations are to
notify consumers uh regarding where they
can call to make a complaint the
challenges that we had with that idea
was we were concerned that because it's
it's not administratively required at
this time we wouldn't really be able to
hold a station accountable if they chose
not to do that so everybody receives a
vehicle inspection report and what we
wanted to do was provide language on
that vehicle inspection report that
would direct a driver who has failed
their safety inspection to where they
need to go so on the vehicle inspection
report if you're familiar with those
right after the section that speaks to
the parts on the car that were found to
be deficient there's a line that we
propose to be added that says concerns
of questions regarding the state
inspection or the practices of
inspection stations may be refer to the
New Hampshire Department of Safety State
Police Troop G at and then there's an
email address address and a phone number
working with the Attorney General's
office and the DMV what we decided was
collectively the way that it would work
is that we could you know start to
funnel those those complaints and then
we could fish them out to the proper
Agency for to address them but at least
we would have an idea of the number of
complaints that were coming in and the
general concerns that were being
presented we thought that this provided
an opportunity for everybody that's
getting a vehicle inspection report to
clearly be notified of where they can
make that
everybody else
thank you for that it sounds good uh
just going along with that is there
currently either in rural or in statute
that you know of
enforcement mechanisms for shops that
are in violation of any of the
administrative rules or if they have bad
audit audits on a regular basis
yes so the way that it works currently
if we go in to do an audit or if we've
received a complaint from a from a you
know a driver of the state that had an
issue with their state inspection and we
go in and conduct an investigation uh
based upon whatever that auditor
investigation reveals there are two
avenues that can be taken which are
administrative action where we could
suspend the license of the station as
well as the mechanic certificate who
performed the inspection or depending on
how egregious it is there are also
criminal charges that could come and
play it as well so there are mechanisms
in place to be able to address those
stations or mechanics that are found to
be you know not performing
thank you I think the egregious ones for
me are the ones that oversell do you
think what we have in place is
sufficient or do we need something with
more teeth or maybe with a more
with a little more reason for people not
to want to do it so if the concern of
the committee is mechanics that are
upselling for
um
services that may not necessarily be
needed the way that it would be
addressed now would be under the
administrative rule for whatever
component that they are trying to upsell
so for example if you had an individual
who was told they needed new brake pads
there's no administrative rule that
speaks to upselling that's not warranted
however the administrative rule says
that you know that the the pads have to
meet that 232nd measurement so if they
are found to be greater than the
violation is the fact that the mechanic
performed an improper inspection and
that's how we would hold them
accountable
mm-hmm
that represents thanks
um just
um when we have uh our subsequent
subcommittee meeting and as we discuss
some of these changes that we're looking
at that you know I I want to make sure
that we are mindful of
nades requirements so that we don't run
a foul of
any environmental things from you know
for air quality Etc
and maybe the Des Department can
continue to attend
and make sure that we you know we we pay
attention to those things because that
is a thorny issue for air quality and
you know and I know Motor Vehicles
provide uh
contribute to oversized amount towards
our air quality issues in the state
yeah again I said I was up to lighting
um
but it's past emissions but I don't know
if it was in there and that's not my
intention at this point uh to go through
these rules and we're just looking at
no no okay
any other questions for Department of
Safety I I think we can probably get
gather a lot more in between this
meeting and the next uh in terms of that
issue the process and and obviously the
complaints we won't know it's a very
good point that if they're going in a
number of different places we'll we
can't get the data right now so
um I I still think we should move
forward with this uh with this direction
yeah go ahead
yeah I'm less concerned with thresholds
on the data because what is likely
happening with a lot of people is they
have now had the worst day of their life
because they have an old cheap car the
repairs May equal the value of the car
and they still have to get to work next
week I don't think they're worried about
complaining about the shop as much as
they are figuring out how to get the
money
if it happens to one person it's too
many for me so you know and we know
what's going on
I agree again I I see no need to cease
what we're doing uh based on the lack of
data for sure
uh any other questions for these two
gentlemen
seeing none thanks very much I'm sure
we'll be talking in the interim
anybody else wish to chime in while
we're here this could be a very brief
meeting which it's okay
is that on or off Becky older Department
of Environmental Services and I just
would like to say thank you for making
it clear that that the intention is not
to remove the requirement for the OBD
inspection overall and Des will
certainly make make a point of being in
other hearings thank you
thank you
all right this is going to be a lot
easier than I thought it was going to be
a bigger topic too on
inspection station education uh one that
came up for me and it was actually a
couple of people so when you look at
your car and you look at the bumper no
you don't you can't see the bumper you
see a giant piece of cosmetic plastic
that adds almost no structural value to
the car at all the Bumper's behind it
so if those are cracked that we had some
shops that were failing the car for a
pretty piece essentially you rip the
thing off the car's still just as safe
as it was
turns out that wasn't the Department's
intent it was if it's busted to the
point that it could fall off it's got
pieces sticking out or something fine
but a simple crack no and what I did was
I had somebody from DMV call the shop
and tell them to stop doing that
it's one shop can't do that for every
shop so I don't know what the answer is
we need a better method when they're
misinterpreting what it is that we want
them to do so I think the rule
referenced initially just damaged bumper
cover that should never have been a rule
doesn't matter if it's damaged it
doesn't matter if your rocker panels are
damaged they're pretty pieces
um what someone who is creative with
older Jeeps figured out was they got
failed for Rusty rocker panels so they
cut them off
and now the vehicle is fine because what
was left under the rocker panel was
solid structural metal that does not
allow exhaust gas to get into the cabin
of the vehicle and we don't want people
getting a Sawzall so that they can pass
an inspection so I don't I don't know
what the bigger um so that's the bigger
topic and I don't know what the bigger
answer is but in general shops
misinterpreting rules are taking them to
the nth degree when we don't want them
to that's a culture we need to change I
don't know where it's coming from but
thank you sir go George
all right well nothing else to
contribute today again
um we're going to continue independently
to go through the rules next meeting we
will have a revised list of the ones
that we want to address by definition uh
in the meantime we'll have conversations
with safety and Department of Motor
Vehicles in terms of nailing down
language on the the the process and
possibly punishment if you will use that
word and see if that needs to go into
statute or if it's sufficient in rules
we can we can we'll have more
information on that
and I think we've already agreed we'll
we'll leave
uh the first year exemption to a
different bill so if there's nobody else
there's nobody here
um nobody else
go ahead representative Smith I had a
question while we have the department of
safety here I see a lot of cars with
blue headlights
a lot of cars with blue headlights and
then another common thing on four models
that I know of is a colored ring around
the headlight and those can be red blue
green those are the three I've seen I
think there's more so they're on the
front of the car right around the
thank you those are called those are
called Halos yeah and there is a
lighting build that's also been
introduced by Yours Truly for the
Department of Safety so I think we have
a vehicle to attach any other questions
what's up I said nice Wick and annoying
glad we're getting that done
lumens too they seem to be getting
brighter and brighter by the day yeah so
if nothing else I'll look during the